[Music]
kim kardashian shows off her skills on
the slopes i was like why not
that's the beauty mogul rocking an
orange jacket and black snow pants
walking into big snow american dream in
new jersey where they've recreated a ski
resort experience indoors
[Music]
and by the looks of it she was having a
good time getting back on the slopes
[Music]
at one point kim even removed her jacket
to show off her black crop top
underneath
and that icy blonde hair is totally
giving us elsa vibes so guess we can say
the cold never bothered kim anyway you
just gotta roll with it now the reality
star skiing ability should come as no
surprise the entire kardashian jenner
fam is avid skiers and snowboarders
which fans saw first hand on keeping up
with the kardashians even though we're
here on a family vacation again
snowboarding is no different i'm all by
myself and my sisters are
off snowboarding together
[Music]
and kylie she's a pretty great
snowboarder herself
oh my god
although we are
so high up the terrain is not as crazy
as i thought it'd be
and it seems like she's passing down
family traditions to her daughter stormy
webster remember when the two-year-old
crushed this ride herself go baby
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah stormy knows how to shred just like
her mama thank you okay but that wasn't
the first time stormy hit the slopes
when she was just 22 months old kylie
shared this clip of the little one
gliding down the snow like a pro
[Music]
you're so cool baby
ghost army go start me ghost army go
stormy
yeah these moves totally run in the
famous family
[Music]